got one more segment that we're gonna do
and this is interesting this is going to
be the most now this is important I know
it is I I've I've been seeing this for
years and years I mean I mentioned
earlier I lived I lived in New York for
15 years I've seen this I've seen them
attack each other Oh what's going away I
go tell people to stop going queue the
news cute queue the news shocking moment
when woman dressed as Minnie Mouse
attacks a security guard on the last
Vegas trip before Mickey and goofy tried
to pull her away I could not resist oh
my goodness I could not resist a story
about Minnie Mouse attacking a security
guard and Mickey and goofy intervening
and like pulling her off I love to
imagine a world where like when it comes
to the Disney characters we're only
seeing their highlights yeah like the
best of their social media posts and and
in reality they are troubled individuals
same as us
Mickey comes home from a hard day's work
on the steamboat and many as you know
kind of grumpy and he's like I've been
working and you're being me and then she
gets all angry gets all drunk nice
goes outside and as a security guard
saying ma'am you can't loiter here
starts Yellin and all sudden Minnie
Mouse's like punch in the security guard
Mickey and goofy come out and they're
like go swimming a pull-off murky okay
let's get to the news look boo boo
here's the actual story there are these
people that dress up like comic book
characters and movie characters and
cartoon characters and they go ask for
money and there's been ongoing problems
with a lot of these but not all of them
because some of them are good saying
people hmm but it attracts a kind of
person and these fights break out and I
don't want to act like it's super common
but it's not super rare yeah it happens
you don't say it happened enough that I
write I heard about it a lot and then in
fact seen it check this out so you can
see this video many is going ham on the
interior art ham poor goofy is like dude
Wow
he's like whoa whoa so here's the pride
almost looked like he was trying to stop
the other person for being involved like
no no don't stop him look Mickey strike
he's like no no don't stop him Mickey
getting in there and then he lifted his
hands like I'm not doing anything I'm
glad I'm glad Mickey was there to try
and break up that fight because that
didn't look like he was trying to stop
it looked like he was for a second well
he was thinking about it but then he's
like whoa toxic masculinity ya know
that's the thing I'm dead serious
actually it's two girls fighting he's
the guy what he accidentally slips and
and then he put his hands up like oh no
no he's like those I saw it yeah look
look at the look on his face - he's like
I'll wait I realize this is not right
yup I can't I can't do this yeah there's
actually there there was a bunch of news
stories I covered this two years ago men
refusing to intervene to help women and
children because of the fear that they
would be labeled an abuser or or
kidnapper or something like that so
there was this famous story oh I should
say famous but this is viral story I was
reading where this this a female
reporter saw a child in a mall who was
not it was like crying
and she saw a guy like walk up look at
the kid and then just like turn around
and walk to the direction and so when
she called security they came and found
the kid and the kids like lost his
parents she asked the guy why he did
that and he was like because if I went
to that kid people would accuse me of
kidnapping I'm like I don't want to I'm
staying I'm keeping my own business
right yeah welcome to the future man I
mean that's maybe males total sense I I
mean we all it takes is that one girl
that might have had an experience of
being afraid of kidnapping sees the guy
going up to some child and it's happened
and just snap and there was I've you
mean girls I mean girls are always right
right it's like a security guard
this guy's kidnapping yep secure guards
gonna go after this dude this happened a
father was with her oh my goodness and
someone pointed him out and said that's
you know he's kidnapping her and they
detained him and took his daughter like
Braun to the station and then they're
like sorry about that
oops like literally a dad and his kid
were going shopping and somebody was
like oh yeah that person who pointed
needs that that should be illegal that
needs to be you that can't be illegal
how false accusations is not illegal
then you get if I were voice someone is
the security guards it's the police it's
it's not it's it's it's a false
imprisonment it's a false attainment the
cons are the ones who to draw that line
yet my my buddy in high school was she
claimed that he raped her and then
admitted two years later that he didn't
that she didn't know that he didn't do
it and and she got she didn't get
anything wrong like she did there
nothing happened to her
he was in prison for two years and and
it's it it's not illegal that's what she
did that's filing a false police report
avoiding somebody I'm saying I'm
suspicious that's on the cop but isn't
that I'm okay I guess you're right yeah
yeah that makes sense let's get back to
many beating up a security guard yeah my
goodness so here's the thing the story's
nothing okay look people fight all the
time the only reason anybody's talking
about this is because it was the middle
who didn't dress up like cartoon care
but what if I were to tell you this
happens all the time it does and it's a
serious problem check out this story mr.
incredible convicted in Hollywood
Boulevard brawl with Batgirl
they love the headlines but why don't
why shouldn't they sir I'm 20 15 in the
Los Angeles Times I used to I lived in
LA for a while but these people do the
stuff everywhere oh and look at those
two there's there's all these different
I can't scroll down for some reason oh
that's just a picture or something oh no
I guess the oh it's the LA Times it's
not working okay oh that's all right so
you've reached your free article limit
is that yeah I'm sure there's all sorts
of different things that happen and I
know that happens more than that too cuz
I lived in New York and I skate skated
around in the city I'm oh I was always
skating and going through Times Square
is one of my runs you know and those
people are all over the place you know
everyone knows The Naked Cowboy like
he's one of the main writers there but
there's always an Elmo there's always
like a you know Space Ranger whatever's
name is you know all sorts of different
anything that's relevant you know in the
the newest Disney movie they're out
there standing there getting pictures of
people you know here's the thing
Naked Cowboy in New York he's a cool
dude he's not really naked no but he's
like walked on in like a speedo playing
the guitar or something yeah and he's
like a regular guy he probably makes
good money doing it he probably kills it
yeah so I live in LA I learned The
Legend of Superman
apparently the guy who started this huh
was it dude who dress up like Superman
he was a regular guy he was clean as he
had a house hmm
and he went around taking pictures of
people and then they start building this
culture up where it started my
understandings in Hollywood eventually
now it's everywhere it's Vegas it's it's
Chicago it's just New York these makes
sense but here's it's creepy man in New
York
check out this this is the light this is
last door we have this is from September
costumed characters keep manhandling
tourists in times yeah this is what I'm
talking about it got to the point where
people who are like degenerate homeless
you know what everyone a calm I don't
want to blame the homeless people for
this problem because these people are
nuts
but these like low-lives go to a
Halloween costume store and spend ten
bucks on a trash costume you know and
walk around smelling awful smelling
awful and not quite inning the outfit
they it will be you can see them they
look dirty
I don't want my picture taken with a
dirty Elmo I want to clean fuzzy Elmo
but then but then the parents the
tourists don't get it
no and they'll walk up take a picture
and then the person will be alike no
money
that'll be money now and they're gonna
be like oh we don't have any I said give
me money and so what happens is these
characters have been grabbing tourists
for a funeral on the leave saying you
can't take a picture with me and then
not pay me and so they were actually
gonna ban it like straight-up ban it I
guess the rule they made was you can't
stop someone from dressing a certain way
like right think about what the law
would be yeah what is the law taking
pictures with people right or they made
it so that you can't demand if you want
to sell the service right so if some
takes a picture with you if they choose
to pay you they choose to pay yeah well
that's that's make sense yeah so I'll
tell you a funny story about whatever
this is it's this weird thing and these
fights are a commonly occurring thing so
I thought it'd be funny to show that
Minnie Mouse fight because look the
media loves a click baiting nonsense
headline yeah so do I sometimes
sometimes sometimes but I thought it was
hilarious like Minnie Mouse gets to a
five security guard honestly though I
was not expecting that vicious of she
was like yeah that was she was gnarly
knew she was bringing Anna let me tell
you a funny story though so I when I
lived in Chicago I used to busk okay
okay busking is when you play music
and/or perform in public and then people
give you money and it's oh I made great
money dude I did too I'm used to it
go take a guitar goes down outside a
Wrigley Field in Chicago play top 40s
play some Neil Young play some credence
you're gonna make like 120 bucks an hour
true it's nuts all the dudes coming out
of the field like you know all drunks
singing the songs with you there I was
yeah this song play Freebird
me and my friend were standing outside a
crocks I lived really close to Wrigley
hunka and when the game ended we were
playing and dude so many drunk guys
would you start singing going like Oh
like really awfully and they'd give us
$1 bills it was nuts they were just
wasted and I'm like my take advantage of
these guys no I'll tell you a funny
story so look we wrap up this costume
characters things like that's the point
I wanted to bring up like these fights
happen all the times all the time but I
was playing guitar in oh you want to
play the the death that you wrap wrap up
with this okay well let me tell the
story they were to show you one of the
most nightmarish things you will ever
see it is it is one of the most
horrifying videos it's there's no
trigger warning there's no gore don't
worry it's just a weird freaky
nightmarish video but let me tell you
this quick story I used to play a guitar
in the subways in Chicago I had a very
beautiful couple hundred our fiberglass
guitar and I remember I would make it I
was making pretty decent money I was
making like 30 bucks an hour because
that's pretty good subway playing but
how long can you play guitar so I'd play
for two three hours
y'okay that's a good day yeah it's a
good day then I put in the bank and go
buy my business so I could I could you
know pay my rent in a few days and I had
food and I loved playing I love singing
and learning new songs and you basically
play like the same seven songs over yep
but I remember two really funny things
somebody I was talking to a friend and
they were like you know hon a date or
something where do you work and I was
like oh I busk and they're like what is
that and I play guitar like in the
subway for cash and she goes like a
homeless person I started laughing I'm
like yeah like a homeless person with a
four hundred dollar fiberglass guitar
yeah what do you what do you think you
think like homeless people just like in
like magically create this expensive
guitar I'm like the people who play
music in Subway's they're not homeless
yeah yeah a lot of those people are
actual musicians that are really
talented people
what's that been hozier is that I say it
hooch hooch no hozier take me to church
so hozier kosher yeah if they played in
the subway like yeah there's a viral
video where they're singing in the
subway like people like performing yeah
where can you perform and it sounds
awesome down there yeah cool yet what it
was like nothing that happened me was
one time I was playing and this woman
came up to me and then very slow like
reached out and she goes there's a
shelter over on
month and I was like thanks I haven't
thanked you I think I'll crash at my
apartment in Bucktown later Bucktown is
like a hipster neighborhood yeah and she
was like uh-oh I was like I really
appreciate it but I hope like you
realize that people down here are
talented mm-hmm some people aren't there
was one guy who would like dance with
the football there's definitely people
that are not good even musician so you
find them and you just like I'm trying
to keep walking they own this guy they
own guitars like if they're not yes sure
yeah so anyway we're gonna leave you
with something that's going to haunt
your dreams I'm going to play for you
this video and I ask you now for your
forgiveness here we go
[Music]
I call this st. Elmo's fire I think
people have called it that seriously
yeah so some of you may just be
listening but this I don't even I don't
even apparently the it was like I think
this is in Philadelphia Philly yeah I
think it was there's a big fire this
like building like lit up and people are
filming this massive fire and they turn
the camera and there's three dudes
banging on these big drums while Elmo
does is weird shuffle dance it's a do
just as Elmo it's look it's not truly
horrifying but I tell you this haunted
me what the first time I it's like it's
it's it's like it's so affiliative
demonic it's like I'm not serious I'm
like they're doing some sort of like
they're doing
Elmo doing this weird dance and there's
like a building burst into flames and
it's like do you think he did that with
his mind like that's the joke Elmo has
like they're doing this this ritual but
you know it's really funny about it is
that the dudes playing music are all
happy and smiling and like having a good
time do you think they even though
there's a fire going on yeah of course
is a cops everywhere
oh yeah that's what I found really
freaky they're like oh that's where
people are let's go yeah let's go jam
that new song guys thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you